-Performing "Last Day on Earth"
from her new EP,
"Our Extended Play",
here's Beabadoobee.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ La la la la ♪
♪ La la la la la ♪
-♪ You made it ♪
♪ It's your last day on Earth ♪
♪ You killed someone
last night ♪
♪ And burned down a church ♪
♪ Oh, you made it ♪
♪ For what it's worth ♪
♪ Well, and if
it all goes wrong ♪
♪ And it looks like
we'll soon be gone ♪
♪ Then we should
all just get along ♪
♪ And sing a song I wrote ♪
♪ And it goes like this,
it goes ♪
♪ Shoop-doop-doo, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo, badoo,
oh yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop-doo, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo, badoo,
oh yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ You made it along ♪
♪ You got a problem with Peter,
you got a problem with John ♪
♪ You can't go on ♪
♪ All this follow me... ♪
♪ I want to get...
at home ♪
♪ Get naked alone ♪
♪ And turn up my phone ♪
♪ 'Cause this song I wrote is
just so...sick, it goes ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Wait, I got something to say ♪
-♪ What's that?
-♪ I forgot, wait a minute ♪
♪ The world's about to end so
I'm gonna have to finish ♪
♪ I guess if it were nicer,
we'd be better off in it ♪
♪ I haven't got a plan, so
I think I'm gonna wing it ♪
♪ Naked, alone with this song
I wrote and it goes like this ♪
♪ It goes shoop-doop-doo,
shoop-doo, badoobadoo ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo, badoo,
oh yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop-doo, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo, badoo,
oh yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
Come on!
♪ Shoop-doop-doo, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo, badoo,
oh yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop-doo, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Shoop-doop, shoop-doo, badoo,
oh yeah ♪
♪ Shoop-doop-doo, shoop-doo,
badoobadoo ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]